hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to part
2 of my Doctor Who 50th anniversary
Easter eggs I thought it'd be fun to try
and find all the hidden references in
the 50th anniversary special but there
were so many that I just had to break it
into two parts this is part two that so
I found about 33 or 34 things in the
first half of the special so let's see
if we can find more in the second half
also I'm getting a lot of questions
about the Christmas special and which
version of the dr. Peter Capaldi is
going to be so I'll be doing a separate
video for that be sure to subscribe to
get it I'll be posting it next Thursday
but the Easter egg hunt begins so this
is going to cover everything in the
second half of the broadcast starting
with the appearance of Captain Jack's
vortex manipulator starting things off
the vortex manipulator code the code
that Matt Smith actually carves into the
wall at the Tower of London is the date
and time of the very first episode of
Doctor Who the painting because Matt
Smith's doctor called from the past for
the security guard to move the painting
before present-day Clara entered the
black archive it's already there when
she first arrives the oldest operating
system in the universe the sonic
screwdrivers are used to open the door
in the Tower of London this works
because each doctor regenerates and gets
a new sonic but the software inside each
sonic stays the same meaning that they
started a calculation that kept running
all the way to the 11th doctor that
makes the operating system sonic OS the
oldest operating system in the universe
next to the operating system of the
moment how old is the doctor Matt Smith
answers that he's about 1200 years old
unless he's lying rule number one the
doctor lies but he also forgets things
Steven Moffat also said in a recent
interview that the doctor has no idea
which number of regeneration he is so
while audiences know him as number 11 he
could actually be a much higher number
you've met them before Matt Smith
reminds Clara that she's met every
single version of the doctor
thanks to jumping into his time stream
during the events of the name of the
doctor however she'd only be able to
remember all of them if the doctor was
able to save her and reintegrate all the
different versions of Clara cuppa soup
the doctor refers to the stasis cube as
a cup of soup why because it's Bachelor
food and as advanced and highly
intelligent as the doctor is he's still
very lonely and totally eats lonely
depressing single-guy food does this
happen a lot the doctor gets kissed a
lot but which doctor gets the most face
time just speaking about the new doctors
before the 50th anniversary special
number nine got kissed
WAIS number 10 got kissed nine times and
number eleven has gotten kissed eight
times so far making David Tennant the
snogging champion pending any kissing in
the 50th anniversary special and the
Christmas special Back to the Future
this is a nice reference to the Back to
the Future franchise but I don't think
that Michael J Fox was on set that day
the round things these are a reference
to the classic doctor's TARDIS's
starting with William Hartnell and up to
the 7th doctors TARDIS each interior had
a similar version of the round things on
the walls you've redecorated I don't
like it tenants doctor says this and
it's the same thing the second doctor
said during the three doctors 10th
anniversary special Matt Smith also says
it's des Craig during closing time in
series 6 the humans don't realize what
half this stuff does so there's a lot of
stuff in the black archive from Doctor
Who's history but most notably River
Song shoes from the time of angels as
well as the Magna clamps the Magna
clamps were first seen in army a ghost
and then later used in doomsday they
cancel an object's mass making large
objects easy to lift we still have no
idea what kind of a weapon of mass
destruction River song shoes are though
the space-time Telegraph this was like
the classic version of the doctor's
phone number that the Fourth Doctor gave
to the Brigadier General he first used
it to summon the doctor during revenge
of the Cybermen and later in terraces
icons the doctors phone number this is
the same phone number that the doctor
had in stolen earth during series 4 the
big red button this flower-like button
is an homage to Rose Tyler because
although Billie Piper is in the special
she's not playing Rose or bad wolf the
sound that TARDIS makes the moment tells
John Hurt that the sound means hope to
all who hear it but River Song already
let us know that the TARDIS isn't
actually supposed to make that sound the
doctor has just been operating it wrong
ever since he stole it or it stole him
for my next trick during the final
montage when all 13 doctors are on
screen in order to make the scene work
the production team used stock footage
from the previous doctors including
Christopher Eccleston who declined to
participate in the episode all 13 so
Peter Capaldi is credited by the High
Council as a doctor during his very
brief cameo but he's not listed in the
credits as a doctor we all know Matt
Smith will regenerate in the Christmas
special but we don't know how Steven
Moffat is going to deal with a 13
regenerations limit
I hope the ears are a bit less
conspicuous this time this is just a
joke about Christopher Eccleston whose
ears stick out from his head a lot the
special effects team actually morph John
Hurt's eyebrows to look just like
Eccleston's during the regeneration I
don't want to go this is a reference to
David Tennant's final words before
regenerating to the 11th doctor Matt
Smith responds with he always says that
the great curator Tom Baker makes his
illustrious appearance in the background
on the wall our circles resembling his
TARDIS and he even tells the 11th doctor
the secret of the painting and that the
doctor might find himself revisiting old
favourite faces in the future this
implies that the doctor eventually finds
a way past his regeneration limit and
since we already know regenerations
could be controlled he can totally be a
future version of the doctor that
regenerated into a similar version of
his fourth self it also opens the door
to the classic doctors appearing on the
show in the future so be sure to write
below in the comments if you saw any
other hidden references that I didn't
mention in the second half of the
special everything from the first half
of the special is in my part 1 video
quick update on the rest of my videos
this weekend since this took so long to
make I'm just going to push my Sherlock
series 3 video 2 before Walking Dead on
Sunday be sure to subscribe to get it
and don't forget on Thursday I'll be
posting that regeneration video talking
about Peter Capaldi's doctor right now
click here for part 1 of my 50th
anniversary Easter eggs and click here
to learn all about the Christmas special
thank you so much for watching high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow